>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Thach Quang Nguyen:
Good morning everybody.
Thank -- thank LOC for giving --
giving me time to be here
to learn from all of you
and to have something
from our --
from me to say to all of you.
When I was 17 years
old, I want to be --
I wanted to be a novelist.
So at that time, I set
up my life to our plight
to ask capital for writing.
And two years in the society
I saw lots of bad things.
So I have found other way to
become a university student.
And when I was 21,
I set my life target
to become Prime Minister
to change Vietnam.
But after one year, after a
shock, when I find a way to --
to help mentor weak woman to
take her home, but I saw problem
with lots of people, but
only one student help me.
So I've got shock.
After taking her home, I
decided to become a library --
a library revolutionary
to change Vietnam.
So here is -- I want to
show what I have been doing.
When I -- when I decided to
become library revolutionary,
I make lots of interview
and to see that, in Vietnam,
rural children do not -- did
not have book for reading.
And school libraries, very
poor, poorly operational.
So that why we have this number.
Now, there's my inter
-- my surveys.
And the other is
from the government.
Here is a very aftermath
of our society.
So,
I took 10 years to
be [Inaudible]
for revolution with
my own money.
And then -- then I develop a
civil library system library
system, which, the first
one is a Clan library.
We base on clan -- a
big family in Vietnam.
Have same ancestor
to build library.
And there are lots
of clan in Vietnam.
And I make a model after
they see it on news on TV.
And very second and very
successful model is the fund --
parent-funded library.
We now in Vietnam, most -- more
than 80% of the people come
from rural area and
they are farmer.
And they have very low income.
Only 50 or 100 U.S. dollar
per month per person.
So I use the most desired model
that the low income parent
can contribute only two
or three U.S. dollar per
year to start the library.
And then their children can
read about more than 50 books.
Only one -- no time for reading.
But they get together
and some more money
and they make big money to do
a big library in the classroom.
And this model becomes very
[Inaudible] in Vietnam.
Lots of social member.
Children can be with
and parent be with.
And [Inaudible] one parish
library we have for about,
in Vietnam, have
about 7 million cities
and these are religious
follower.
So we build that
structure to build library.
So, in coming years,
it's about --
I predict about 1 million
religious children have a book
because every case the
Catholic system to do that.
And I also built back-front
military officer library.
Because in newer area, the
military officer and police
and [Inaudible] teacher
have a good, stable income.
So we develop this so that
many family, they build library
for your children and
villager to read it.
Here, achievements.
I think now it is easy --
not easy to count the number
of library increase daily.
And
now more than 20,000
library already built.
And this number is increasing
very fast -- rapidly.
And about 300,000 Vietnamese
and oversee Vietnamese engaged
in building and many people
from America contribute
money to build it.
And now, more than 1 million
rural readers have benefit
from my -- our system.
And here is a very
big number for me.
Number of book borrowed by rural
student has increased from zero
to 12.5 books per year
to 10 to 30 per year.
Yeah.
Because we, when the library in
the classroom, they're reading.
Very easy for them to
read and to access it.
And in achievements, you know,
many parent in rural
area are now,
they're reading books
for their children.
That is never before.
Two libraries model include
in the government system.
Minister of Education
and Minister
of Culture already got two
models into their system.
So we have NGO and UNESCO
cooperate in 2009 and last year.
And now we are develop
STEM education.
It's an American model so it --
we make recycle STEM
in rural area.
[Laughter] Yeah.
Here is the [Inaudible] Deputy
Prime Minister work with me
and we will develop the
system faster and faster.
Ongoing work.
We are building a master plan
to attract 10 million children
to use lucky money
to build library.
And yearly about 50 million
U.S. dollar for [Inaudible]
for the children in the New
Year [Inaudible] in Vietnam.
And we are -- we are --
I am trying to learn the
reading encouragement strategies
from U.S. organizations
for adapting
and applying in Vietnam.
And I will also developing
reading encouragement models
to apply both in college -- in
school and in the community.
So it's my want -- my
desire -- my ambition again.
In 2015, I go after about
4 million first step
to raise awareness for
the Vietnamese people
and to advocate the
policy for Vietnam.
And now it is already
success -- success.
So I want to use my footsteps
to power footsteps to walk
around the worlds to make
a kind of global campaign
for reinforcing right to
read for the world children.
So I am very happy today to say
[Inaudible] from India here.
So I want to organize
the country to raise fund
for local library organizations
like Pratham Book classroom.
Desire to devote -- I
desire to devote my --
the rest of my life
to the world children.
You see after 2 million children
in India cannot own a book
because of the cost is a
figure of Pratham Book.
So I hope that -- I have
only one, only one eye.
Blind already.
So I hope that before the remain
blind, I have a chance to walk
around the world to raise
problem about reading --
about lack of reading
for the children,
lack of move forward children,
and I hope that we all here
shake hands to make a change
in the international scope
to have all children
have a book to read.
As you know, you do not go
[Inaudible]
about seven -- more than
750 million children,
people in the world, illiterate.
So we -- so shake
hands to keep it down.
All right?
So it is starting from building
library for the children.
So I hope that next year in
2008 the Pratham Book and I,
we can shake hands together.
I can walk in your country
about 1 million -- no --
1,000 kilometer from
[Inaudible] to raise and to call
in the Indian people
to shake hands
to replicate some of those.
Some of those very excellent.
So, thank you again.
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.